[Musique]
ça veut tout simplement dire qu'on en a
marre que des enfants se fassent tuer à
l'est du Congo depuis des années il y a
des femmes qui sont violées des enfants
qui travaillent dans des NES on est
fatigué cela se passe il faut que ça
cesse on veut faire passer tout
simplement un message à travers la canne
par que le monde entier en train de
regarder cette canne cette demi-finale
et on en profite afin que cela soit
médiatisé le seul message que j'ai à
faire passer là maintenant c'est que le
monde entier puisse se souvenir de l'Est
du Congo à Goma précisment où les
génocide est en train de détruire les
vies et c'est ce qui écur tous les
Congolais on est fatigué du silence par
rapport à ça c'est le message que j'ai à
faire
passer làbord on souffre c'est pour ça
on a porté ça ça c'est l'exemple hein
pour dire que oui on est là on est à
deil tout monde nous regarde le football
c'est quand même ce qu'on appelle sport
ro donc tout le monde regarde le
football donc on profite l'occasion pour
lancer le message de paix chez nous donc
on a vraiment besoin de paix ouis
l'argent histoire des combats tout ça
nous on s'en fout de ça donc on a besoin
que les gens vivent leur vie
[Musique]
tranquillement